[موسيقى]
هي ذات المشاهد لم تتغير
بذات الخطى ونفس طريق النزوح او اللجوء
الطويل بين الجبال
[موسيقى]
بنادق دفاعيه على اكتافهم في الحاضر
وامنيات سابقه لم تتحقق من الماضي
[موسيقى]
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه تحقق اخيرا
حلم الكرد بدوله مستقله جمعتهم من الشتات
ومهدت الطريق امام حق تقرير المصير
[موسيقى]
لكنها لم تدم سوى عام واحد حاصرها الجيش
الايراني واسقطها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صوره اخرى تتكرر هنا في جبال كردستان
العراق غارات من حين لاخر على مواقع حزبكم
للايرانيه المعارض تذكره بان مطالبه وبقيت
الاحزاب الكرديه بالمساواه والديمقراطيه
غير مقبولتين بعد
نحن لا نحمل الاسلحه لبدء حرب لدينا هذه
الاسلحه للدفاع عن انفسنا في الوقت الذي
تهاجمنا فيه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ليلا
ونهارا اهدافنا هي ان نضمن يوما مع
العداله الاجتماعيه في بلدنا نريد لوطننا
ان يكون حرا وان يكون الرجال والنساء
متساويين
مساواه لن يقبل بها النظام الايراني
القائم على مبدا ولايه الفقيه فمن يعارضه
يهدد حكمه والمبدا نفسه الذي تعامل معه
المرشد الايراني الخميني الذي عاد من
المنفى بسبعينات القرن الماضي لم يقبل
كوميلا والاحزاب الاخرى لحكم الخميني
وقامت الثوره فوجه المرشد جميع قواته الى
كردستان ايران حاصرها وقمعها لتبدا قصه
اللجوء الى العراق في هذه المعسكرات التي
اصبحت وطنا بديلا
لا يمكنني العوده الى ايران للمشاركه في
الاحتجاجات لكنني ساخدم شعبي بكل فخر وانا
مقاتل بشمركه حتى اليوم الذي نحققه فيه
اهدافنا
وحتى تتحقق اهدافهم لابد من ملجا امن في
هذه الساحه من معسكر كوما لا تجتمع
الفتيات يشاركنا في التدريب
ثم يتوجهن الى ما تعرف بغرف الطياره وهي
غرف محصنه مدفونه بالجبال يقضين فيها ما
تبقى من يومهن يعيشن حياه الفتيات لكن
هناك ما يذكرهن دائما فانهن لسنا في مامن
تامه
[موسيقى]